Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new Marvel Deadpool 3
video we've also got some deleted scenes
from the other Deadpool movies will
breakdown if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
theories about Deadpool 3 on the video
so we'll talk about the deleted scenes
first then I'll talk about the Deadpool
3 stuff starting with number 5 Ryan
Reynolds has been posting a lot of
Deadpool stuff the last couple of weeks
as people have been stuck inside their
homes inside the United States because
of the virus recently he posted a brand
new deleted scene from the first
Deadpool movie with Deadpool going fool
Kenny Rogers during the big bridge fight
scene because Kenny Rogers had just
passed away in real life so r.i.p Kenny
Rogers
here's that deleted scene that's just an
example of the different things that
they'll do on all the Deadpool movies
they did the same thing on Deadpool 2
there are a billion different versions
of scenes that they work on they
workshop jokes there are a lot of
reasons why some of this stuff doesn't
make it into the actual cut of the film
but number 4 if you guys didn't see it
Ryan Reynolds did talk about what's
going on with Deadpool 3 he's been
meeting with Marvel as you can see he's
been posting pictures from inside the
belly of the beast he went on some talk
shows last year to promote his charity
but was also asked about what's going on
with Deadpool 3 this is the clip of him
confirming that they're actually working
on it right now actively even though
they're homebound they're still working
on this story obviously they're not
going to be filming Deadpool 3 for a while
plans for yet another Deadpool in the
French yeah yeah we're working on it
right now with the whole team we're over
at Marvel
yeah like issues the big leagues all of
a sudden it's kind of crazy so yeah
we're working on woody says they're
working on it right now he's just
talking about the actual story Marvel
has a lot of movies that are in story
development phase before they actually
rush into production number three who's
coming back so as you saw Ryan Reynolds
is one of the few x-men based characters
at Fox to survive the latest of many
snaps think of the reboot of all the
x-men characters at Marvel the Fantastic
Four characters it's just the latest in
a line of snaps currently the only
people reported to be coming back for
Marvel's Deadpool 3 are Ryan Reynolds
himself as Deadpool Colossus Morena
Baccarin Savannah Josh Brolin's Cable
because he signed a five picture deal at
Fox in Domino TJ Miller's weasel was
already out at Fox when they were still
making Deadpool 3 at Fox he was already
not going to continue in the movies when
they still had their original plans and
there's no mention of negasonic teenage
warhead either so she might not come
back but that hasn't been confirmed so
whatever their plans are now in terms of
story for Deadpool 3 it sounds like the
rest of the cast will be a mixture of
new core Marvel Studios characters in
x-men based characters there have been
rumors about new writers and new
directors coming in for Deadpool 3 I
don't know if the rumor about new
writers coming in is true Paul Wernick
in Rhett Reese have been the writers on
Deadpool since way back when they
started developing it in 2008 this saga
of Deadpool goes back to 2008 after
Wolverine Origins but I do think the
report about Marvel wanted to bring on a
new director for Deadpool 3 is true now
as for who that director is is in
question there are a lot of rumors about
them wanting to get Tycho YTD to do
Deadpool 3 but here's the thing with
that way back around thor ragnarok Taika
Waititi had heard that Marvel might get
its characters back because they had
just started the Fox Disney buyout deal
so he was replying to people on Twitter
saying that would be great to do
Deadpool inside a Thor movie or use the
Deadpool character in some way or do a
new Deadpool movie so we just sound like
he was a big fan of Ryan Reynolds in the
Deadpool character here's the thing
about that though he hasn't said
anything about it since then and that
was a couple of years ago and he's
getting ready to start shooting Thor for
love and thunder before the end of this
year so if he's also going to do
Deadpool 3 he wouldn't be able to start
on that till 2022 after he finishes
releasing Thor 4
right now the target release date for
Deadpool 3 at Marvel in Marvel phase 5
is 2022 or 2023
so I think that kind of takes tyka out
of the running because it would take
about two years to develop the movie and
he wouldn't be able to start on it till
2022 that means they wouldn't be able to
release his version of it till 2024 so
you're free to fan cast any kind of
director you want at this point here's
the funny thing though number two I
just did a fantastic four video I've
done a couple about what Marvel is doing
with the new Fantastic Four characters
and Easter eggs in the MCU but there was
actually a bunch of deleted scenes of
the Fantastic Four in Deadpool two
before they finished making that movie
originally they had plans to include
Fantastic Four characters because who
better to use for comedy than the
maligned Fantastic Four they've had so
many bad runs at Fox they kind of did
the same thing with the Deadpool
character like they kind of trash him
during Wolverine Origins then they wind
up doing this really awesome version of
the character in the Deadpool movie so
why not try the same thing with the
Fantastic Four characters so as you see
from the concept art that they did for
the movie this would have been the
version of the Fantastic Four from the
2015 Josh Trank Fantastic Four who
better to make fun of right what
happened with that though is that was
early on and it was Tim Miller's version
of Deadpool 2 he eventually left the
project because he said most of his
decision-making power had been taken
away from the studio and he didn't want
have to direct someone else's version of
Deadpool he wanted to do his version of
Deadpool david leitch was hired to come
on and take over the movie and by the
time they had gotten started Michael B
Jordan wasn't available anymore because
he was signing on to play kill monger in
the Black Panther movie in the people at
Fox just wanted everyone to forget about
that Fantastic Four movie so they took
that giant story arc out of the movie
and replaced it with all the juggernaut
scenes and more x-force scenes so what
would have happened in the Deadpool 2
Fantastic Four scenes is you have
Deadpool facing off against the
Fantastic Four as part of this larger
mutant plot they were still doing that
part of the film but where has that lead
really hard on the x-mansion in the
x-men Dark Phoenix cameo seen during
Deadpool 2 you have to imagine them just
replacing some of that stuff with
Fantastic Four scenes which I think may
have actually been more fun even though
it was cool to see the x-men finally
show up in
Deadpool movie when they replaced some
of that Fantastic Four stuff with the
juggernaut stuff also as a way to save
money they actually had Ryan Reynolds do
the voice of juggernaut so even though
they spent way more money making
Deadpool 2 they still did try to save
money by not including a bunch of extra
characters because Kevin Feige and
Marvel are rebooting the Fantastic Four
inside the MCU in Deadpool 3 is kind of
going to be its own self-contained thing
that's rated R whereas most of the MCU
movies in tone are pg-13 that's probably
why the Fantastic Four is going to be
off limits for Deadpool 3 as cool as it
would be to see them reference all that
stuff even if you can't include those
characters in number 1 there been
rumors about them referencing the Omega
red character during the Black Widow
movie because they're going to be in Russia
so there's going to be a lot of Russian
Marvel comic book characters reference
in addition to red Guardian and people
we haven't seen before
but during Deadpool 2 there's a deleted
scene with Omega red that they finished
inside the prison the Deadpool gets sent
to it was really big as surprising that
it didn't make the final cut of the film
because it would have been really cool
Omega Red
you're going to go to makeup or you just as
is ya know I skipped it for today
what are your parish carbonadium through
my veins kinda same I'm like the Russian
Wolverine let off like pheromones so
people can't get close to you or will
die and super strong is too fragile
we'll chat you know some keep me busy
you know to play between packs really
camera
speaking of other Russian comic book
characters during the Black Widow movie
hopefully they'll reference whiplash in
his father Crimson Dynamo because it's
been a while since we've seen him in
Iron Man 2 the only thing that's really
awful limits to Deadpool is actually
putting someone like Robert Downey jr.
or someone like Chris Evans in the movie
they can make fun of those characters
like Deadpool can make fun of Iron Man
he can make fun of any of the Avengers
but actually putting a lot of the
mainstream Avengers inside the movie is
a bit off limits Ryan Reynolds is still
trying to get Hugh Jackman to come back
and do more Wolverine stuff even though
he's adamant that he is permanently
retired so if they find any way to
convince him to do stuff with Deadpool 3
I think it would just be Hugh Jackman
cameo as Hugh Jackman or just doing
Wolverine jokes and then showing Hugh
Jackman pictures so remember to keep
your expectations realistic but if Ryan
Reynolds starts talking about Deadpool 3
again revealing any more details I'll
totally do a new video leave all your
requests in the comments below while you
wait for everything click here to learn
about all the Marvel movies that have
been either delayed or cancelled this
year and click here for all the
Fantastic Four Easter eggs in the MCU
movies so far thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!